Speaker 1: Let's try Ricky from Charlotte and
see if Ricky from Charlotte can help us recover.
Ricky, welcome to the program.
What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hey, David can hear me.
Speaker 1: I can hear you beautifully.
Speaker 2: Okay, cool. Yeah. So I wanted to ask
you about this right wing civil war that we see
starting to unfold. Yeah. And I'm. I'm just
curious. I'm not exactly sure. Like, what the
like what the dividing lines around this
will be. I mean, I guess we could say, like,
in the context of going into the 2024 primary,
which could be the Trump versus DeSantis line.
But I'm really curious about like what the
fracture will make, you know, like what the
Civil War will make them look like fractured after
like this whole thing is done. And whether there
could be like any sort of permanent split that
could benefit the left ego from asking 100%.
Speaker 1: And it's a really hard thing to
predict, but it's a really astute thing to
be wondering about because up until two weeks ago,
really the dividing line has been you've got your
pro-Trump and your anti-Trump Republicans. Fine.
When the speaker vote came, that ultimately led to
Kevin McCarthy becoming speaker of the House,
you had a further subdivision of that where
you had anti-Trump, but then you had pro-Trump
that likes McCarthy and pro-Trump that says we
need an alternative. So it was like Marjorie
Taylor GREENE versus Lauren Boebert. The 24
election is going to be its own thing because, for
example, you're completely right. You've got the
DeSantis and Trump part of it. But now you also
have, for example, Nikki Haley. Nikki Haley worked
in the Trump administration. She was Trump's
ambassador to the U.N., but now she's running
against Trump. But the other wrinkle to it is
Trump actually needs as many people as possible to
jump into the primary, because if you look at head
on one on one polls between Trump and DeSantis,
it's very good for DeSantis. When you include
more people in the polls, it's better for Trump
because they take away support from DeSantis.
So it's weird because Nikki Haley is a former
Trump staffer who's running against Trump, but
Trump actually benefits from the field being
more divided. So you're asking a really great
question, which is after it all shakes out,
then what does the party look like? And it depends
whether Trump wins or doesn't win. If Trump loses
the primary, whatever the split is between now
and July of 2024, if Trump loses the primary,
all bets are off in the sense that there will be
a realignment of the Republican Party altogether.
And they might even say, Hey, you know, we also
don't want the Marjorie Taylor GREENE, get them
all the hell out of here. If Trump does win the
primary, then there will be a question of whether
the anti-Trump Republicans have had enough.
And they want to really try to do something
invoking force majeure or something along those
lines. It's so hypothetical, Ricky, that I
don't know. But it's a fascinating question.
Speaker 2: Yeah. No, I'm. I'm really curious
to see where it goes. But, like, my general
thing is, I just hope that it causes, like,
permanent lasting damage. You know, I believe,
like, what Chomsky said, that the Republican
Party is the most dangerous organization in human
history. And so I just root for their downfall.
And it's been really interesting to see how some
of the infighting that we've seen over the last
few years sort of on the left, at least like in
the independent media space. Yeah. Seems to be
really consuming the right because the right, you
know, the Republican Party and the right seems to
be like more closely united with their whole
like Internet culture and independent media
culture. So I don't know if you've seen some of
these characters like a Laura Loomer she's this
really crazy far right like yeah Nick French is
adjacent I'm familiar with. Yeah. And she's like,
going hard and yet she's like essentially leading
like a Trump or bust movement for 2024. And
they're calling DeSantis essentially calling
his stance like a lefty and all this stuff.
Speaker 1: And the interesting thing about that,
Ricky, if I may, is some of that infighting that
took place on the left, it's with people that
we now all know aren't really on the left. Like,
it's so it's so funny to give a couple
examples, Jimmy Dora and Glenn Greenwald,
I don't know if you're familiar with them.
It's funny because at one point it was sort
of well-accepted that they're part of, quote, the
left. But then as the infighting began, it kind of
became clear that they're kind of reactionary
libertarian populists, really. And that is
not exactly on the left. And now, you know, Jimmy
Dore is doing his own thing. And Glenn Greenwald,
I think, is on like Rumble or something like that.
I don't hear anyone on the left still considering
them part of the left anymore. And it's sort of
like become very clear that a lot of these people
really weren't on the left, if that makes sense.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I think. Well, yeah, I know that
like Jimmy and there are some others are not like
Michael Tracey or some of these other people,
especially like around the issues like the Ukraine
war claimed to be like the true left is still and
I just think that the interesting thing with
that is and this can be my conspiracy theory,
I think a lot of those characters are
being played by like some sort of NATO
deal, you know, in order for them to get
rich. And they never really believed in
interest in doing the shift that they
believed in. But I just hope that,
like I would love to see a similar thing like
that actually happened to the right, because I
feel like it could be more damaging because that's
more tied to their, like mainstream culture than,
you know, the left independent media is.
Speaker 1: Hundred percent because these
characters on the right that are involved in
these tiffs, they really are on the right.
Like when when the Jimmy Dore thing happened,
it was like, Oh, this guy's not on the left,
but these right wingers really are on
the right. It's not like, oh, you know,
it turns out Laura Loomer is actually a
leftist. Like, obviously that's not exactly.
So it has the potential to be much more damaging.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Okay. Well, let's hope it works.
Speaker 1: Let's hope. All right,
my friend. Thank you very much.
There's Ricky from Charlotte. Great to hear from
him. Let's go next to Johnny from Toronto. We will
go to our friendly neighbors to the north.
Johnny from Toronto, I I'm inviting you to
speak. Once you accept and properly configure
your audio device, hopefully you and I will be
able to have dialog like.
Speaker 2: Hey, David.
Speaker 1: Can you hear me? I can hear you fine.
Speaker 2: All right, David. Sir, it's so great
to be here. I kind of have tears in my eyes. I
hope my audio is not too bad, but I just had a
quick question. Yeah, in relation to your workout
program. Okay. I remember a few a few months back,
you mentioned that you work quite comfortable
going back to the gym. I'm back at the moment,
yes. I was just kind of interested and
curious if you had a workout program and
what that looked like. And just I had
a follow up question to this as well.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, so so just to make
sure I didn't step on you, I am back at the
gym at this time. Not literally now. Right now
I'm in my studio. But I mean, I'm I'm going to
the gym. I basically alternate forms of cardio
between running elliptical and rowing machine and
then rotate through different weight lifting
elements targeted at different parts of the
body. I hit the body with weight.
Speaker 2: Okay, Got to go. Yeah.
And I guess my follow up question was, I
remember a few weeks back at this point,
there was someone who I think they left you
a voicemail or an email or they said that,
Oh, you're like £150. I don't even remember.
I call you a date or something. Yeah. And I'm
just wondering, do you think it's kind of a bit
of a humorous question or do you think people
on the right might take you slightly more
seriously if you decided to like, bulk up
and gain £20 of muscle or something like that?
Speaker 1: You know, I'm not sure, number one,
because it's not really that obvious when looking
at screens, I don't think. And as a counter,
I got word through our team that Ben SHAPIRO has
been lifting weights and apparently has put on
some some, you know, modest amount of muscle. And
I don't see anyone taking him any more seriously.
Speaker 2: Okay. I understood.
Got it. Well, thank you for
the opportunity to talk, man. I appreciate.
Speaker 1: It. All right. Johnny from Toronto,
thank you very much. Important questions
for sure that I can't can't ignore those
types of questions because they are
critical to the culture war, I would say.